wir sind wieder da für euch ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr bei uns zu Gast seid
im Stream es ist das größte
Atomkraftwerk Europas und es liegt
inmitten des Kriegsgebiets das
russischen angriffskriegs gegen die
Ukraine es geht um das Atomkraftwerk
saporicia immer wieder kommt es da auch
zu Gefechten und auch zu Ausfällen des
AKWs und immer wieder gibt es natürlich
auch die große Sorge um die Sicherheit
frische Erkenntnisse über die
Sicherheitslage hat heute Nachmittag die
Internationale Atomenergieorganisation
veröffentlicht eine Delegation war da in
den vergangenen Tagen vor Ort und konnte
sich ein Bild machen über die
Sicherheitslage darüber sprechen wir
heute und vor allen Dingen natürlich
auch über die Erkenntnisse mit einem
Experten mit dem Atomexperten Sebastian
stranski und unserer zdf-korrespondentin
Katrin Eigendorf sie ist immer wieder
für uns in der Ukraine vor Ort auch
jetzt und da sind natürlich noch mal die
Schwerpunkte die aktuelle militärische
Frage und natürlich auch die Lage an der
Front Fragen an beide wie immer sehr
gerne direkt in die Chats oder per Mail
oder per App an ZDF
heute-zdf.de Adresse wird gerade
eingeblendet Haut die gerne rüber und
wir leiten das dann weiter
im ersten Schritt haben jetzt aber
erstmal Arndt Ginzel und Jürgen Kehl die
frischesten Informationen und auch
Bilder aus saporisha
unterwegs auf Ukrainisch kontrolliertem
Gebiet zu einem der wohl gefährlichsten
Orte Europas das Team von Reporter Arndt
Ginzel dreht aktuelle Bilder vom
Atomkraftwerk saporicia 6 Reaktorblöcke
mit nimkriegsgeschehen Notstrombetrieb
Schäden an Stromleitungen nach neuen
Einschlägen melden die Betreiber
Russland hält die Anlage besetzt und
macht erneut Kiew verantwortlich
in den letzten 24 Stunden gab es 15
ukrainische artillerieangriffe auf die
Stadt in Agoda und auf das AKW saporicia
Kiew weist dies postwenden zurück so
geht das seit Monaten fest steht nur das
geschossen wird und dass die Welt den
Atem anhält
Inspektoren der internationalen
Atomaufsicht haben sich die Anlage
ansehen können sie sprechen nun in ihre
mit Spannung erwarteten Bericht von
einer bisher beispiellosen Gefahr
daher ist das dringend notwendig
Maßnahmen zu ergreifen die helfen einen
Atomunfall durch Kriegshandlungen zu
verhindern das kann durch die sofortige
Einrichtung einer Schutzzone Geschehen
ein dringender Auftrag an die Diplomatie
wie geht es weiter mit Europas größtem
Atomkraftwerk wie kann es gelingen
saporicia aus der Schusslinie zu
bekommen
ja darüber sprechen wir jetzt natürlich
direkt mit unserem Experten mit
Sebastian stranski er ist von der
Gesellschaft für Anlagen und
Reaktorsicherheit schönen guten Abend
Herr stranzki nach Berlin da sind sie
zugeschaltet vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
und dass sie uns heute helfen die Fakten
rund um diese Lage zu sortieren
die Internationale
Atomenergieorganisation hat heute einen
Bericht einen Abschlussbericht über die
sogenannte sicherheitsmission
vorgestellt und was beim ersten Lesen
der auffällt sie schreiben da von
Schäden in einem Gebäude wo unter
anderem auf frischer Kernbrennstoff und
radioaktiver Müll gelagert werden soll
das klingt jetzt erstmal beim Lesen
gefährlich ist das auch so das ist
im jetzigen Zustand nicht gefährlich
gewesen weil es durch den Beschuss nicht
zu Schäden an dem Brennstoff oder an den
eingelagerten radioaktiven Stoffen
gekommen ist hätte es diese Schäden
gegeben die es zum Glück nicht gegeben
hat wäre ein Austritt von Radioaktivität
höchstens im Weichbild des Gebäudes oder
auf dem Kraftwerksgelände spürbar
gewesen es hätte also keine weitflächige
Kontamination gegeben
gibt es andere Bereiche die vielleicht
nicht so sensibel gesichert sind
abklingbetten zum Beispiel was hinter
ihre Informationen das abklebecken ist
ein Brennelement Lagerbecken was ich im
Inneren des Reaktorgebäudes befindet
dort werden die Brennelemente wenn sie
aus dem Reaktor ausgeladen werden
hineingesetzt das ist wie ein
schwimmbadseng muss man sich vorstellen
und sie verbleiben dort mindestens für
fünf Jahre um soweit abzuklingen bis man
sie dann in sogenannte Transport und
Lagerbehälter verladen kann und diese
Transport und Lagerbehälter werden so
ist es am Standort saporizia geregelt in
das Brennelement Zwischenlager verbracht
was im Norden des Kraftwerksgeländes
installiert worden ist gehen wir ein auf
diese
Sicherheitskontrolle von der
Organisation und die Erkenntnisse des
Berichts vielleicht ganz kurz bevor wir
uns dem Detail angucken aus ihrer Sicht
was war das da für eine Mission und was
wurde für eine Gefahrenlage allgemein
festgestellt
die Mission war lange lange schon
gefordert der Herr grossy hat ja schon
zu Beginn des Krieges Russlands gegen
die Ukraine und spätestens seitdem die
ersten russischen Truppen in das
Weichbild des krankhafers gekommen sind
gesagt wir müssen eigentlich dringend
dahin als IAEO als unabhängige
Organisation die für die Aufsicht über
die Kernkraftwerke zuständig ist um zu
schauen wie geht es da was passiert dort
und wie ist die Situation des Kraftwerks
das hat ja dann lange diplomatische
Verhandlungen und Verwicklungen gegeben
und der größte hindernispunkt für diese
Mission war ja über welchen Weg reißt
die Mission an über ukrainisches
Territorium oder über russisches
Territorium das konnte dann zum Glück
gelöst werden und letzten Montag sind
dann die 14 Experten die losgefahren
alles Mitarbeiter der IAEO und haben
sich ungefähr vier Tage wenn man den
Donnerstag als vollen Tag mal mitnimmt
das Kraftwerk angeguckt nicht alle der
Hauptteil der Delegation ist ja
Donnerstag abend schon wieder abgereist
aber fünf Leute sind bis Sonntag da
gewesen und haben die Punkte die man
Donnerstag in einer erst Besichtigung
sich angeguckt hat sich etwas genauer
angeguckt ja da sprechen sie schon an es
gibt konkrete Erkenntnisse und vor allen
Dingen auch Empfehlungen aus dem Bericht
und die schauen wir uns jetzt mal
gemeinsam an die haben wir für euch
vorbereitet das ist zum einen die
Forderung nach einer nuklearen
Sicherheitszone rund um das
Atomkraftwerk das ist eine der
Forderungen eine der Empfehlungen der
zweite Punkt das ist auch das russische
Panzerfahrzeuge die in turbinenhaltigen
stationiert sein sollen die so ein
abgezogen werden der dritte Punkt
ukrainische Mitarbeiter Verbesserung der
Lage wird gefordert ein weiterer Punkt
die Sorge auch über die Unterbrechung
der Stromversorgung der Anlage ja und
natürlich auch die mangelhafte
Kommunikationseinrichtungen die gerade
da in der Notfallzentrale am Start sein
soll
Herr stranski lassen Sie uns die Punkte
nochmal Stück für Stück durchgehen die
Forderung nach einer nuklearen
Sicherheitszone rund um das
Atomkraftwerk aus ihrer Sicht was
braucht es da um die schnellstmöglich
einzurichten und was könnte das bringen
oder vielleicht sogar der russischen
Politik in Moskau denn die russische
Armeeführung oder die Politik in Moskau
sind die einzigen die diese nukleare
Sicherheitszone herstellen können denn
das Kraftwerk und das Kraftwerksgelände
ist durch russische Truppen besetzt und
in dem Augenblick wo die russischen
Truppen abziehen und sagen okay wir
verzichten darauf dieses
Kraftwerksgelände besetzt zu halten gäbe
es auch keinen Grund dieses
Kraftwerksgelände in irgendwelche
Kampfhandlungen mit einzubeziehen
sondern man könnte sich darauf
verständigen dass um das Kraftwerk herum
eine Zone geschaffen wird durch die
nicht gekämpft wird wenn man sich das
anguckt ist das eigentlich relativ
einfach das Kraftwerk ist liegt ja auf
einer Halbinsel oder zumindestens auf so
einem Landstück an einem See und auf der
anderen Seite des Sees nordwestlich und
nördlich ist Ukrainisch kontrolliertes
Territorium das und einige Kilometer ich
weiß nicht ob es jetzt 10 oder 20 km
sind aber ist durchaus eine erklägliche
Entfernung und östlich und südlich vom
Kraftwerksgelände befindet sich östlich
befindet sich die Stadt Ernährung da und
südlich davon russisch besetztes
Territorium das heißt wenn klassische
Armee sich von diesen Territorium
zurückziehen würde dann könnte man
relativ einfach eine Ringzone um das
Kraftwerk von 10 oder 20 km im
Durchmesser schaffen
der zweite Punkt russische
Panzerfahrzeuge die jetzt in
turbinenhallen stationiert sein die
sollen abgezogen werden was ist da die
Erklärung dahinter
ja das ist etwas wo wir nur mutmaßen
können was wir wissen ist dass in der
Turbinenhalle des Blockes eins und des
Blockes 2 Equipment ich sage es mal
militärisches Equipment steht ob das
Panzerfahrzeuge sind ob das Waffen sind
ob das Munition ist oder was auch immer
das wissen wir nicht genau die Ukraine
haben gemeldet die russische Armee hat
dort Waffen und Munition untergebracht
ob das stimmt wie gesagt lässt sich
nicht überprüfen aber fest steht eine
Turbinenhalle ist so ziemlich der letzte
Ort wo man militärisches Equipment
unterstellen sollte und daher muss man
ehrlicherweise da nicht ehrlicherweise
da muss man klipp und klar sagen das
gehört da so schnell wie möglich
weggebracht das hatte auch zum Beispiel
zur Folge dass die ukrainische
Aufsichtsbehörde es in der EU diesen
beiden Blöcken den die Erlaubnis die
Genehmigung zum Leistungsbetrieb
entzogen hat
ja danke dass Sie das noch mal so
klarstellen und und einordnen wichtig
wahrscheinlich auch bei diesem Aspekt
das geht um die ukrainischen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter die da
immer noch unter diesen Bedingungen
unter diesem Druck gerade arbeiten was
konkret braucht es dafür Verbesserung
und wie geht es den da gerade über
überhaupt wie es Ihnen geht wissen wir
natürlich nicht weil wir haben keinen
direktem Kontakt zu ihnen es gibt ja nur
ein telefonischen Kontakt oder Kontakt
über die sozialen Medien innerhalb des
Landes bzw auch zu ukrainischen
Aufsichtsbehörde was man sich natürlich
durchaus vorstellen kann dass wenn man
über Monate und mittlerweile sind es ja
mehr als fünf Monate unter Besatzung
arbeitet das heißt wenn man zum
Kraftwerksgelände reingeht muss man ein
Kontrollposten passieren wenn man zum
Kraftwerksgelände rausgeht muss man
einen Kontrollposten passieren
wahrscheinlich werden sie auch Soldaten
auf dem Kraftwerksgelände selbst
begegnen das erzeugt aus meiner Sicht
durchaus eine psychischen Druck der
natürlich den Stresspegel erhöht und
eines der Grundprinzipien der
kerntechnischen Sicherheit ist die
stressfre Betätigung der
Kraftwerksmitarbeiter das Arbeiten
entsprechenden Betriebsvorschriften ohne
einen äußeren Druck und das haben wir
hier natürlich nicht und vor dem
Hintergrund würde ich gerne für die
Mitarbeiter mal eine Lanze brechen aus
meiner Sicht leisten sie großartiges
denn soweit wir wissen arbeiten die
sechs Blöcke ob sie jetzt abgeschaltet
sind oder im Betrieb sind im
Normalbetrieb das klingt paradox aber
die Anlagen befinden sich nach der
Klassifizierung der Betriebszustände von
Reaktoren im Normalbetrieb und das ist
durchaus auch der dem engagierten
Einsatz der Mitarbeiter und der Umsicht
der Mitarbeiter zu verdanken die trotz
der äußeren Bedingungen ihren Job
wirklich gut machen
absolut der vierte Aspekt die Sorge über
die Unterbrechungen der Stromversorgung
der Anlage vielleicht können Sie uns das
erklären was ist da der Hintergrund und
was muss getan werden es ist so dass
wenn Sie ein Kernkraftwerk Betreiben der
Reaktor oder der Inhalt des Reaktors
auch nach dem Abschalten das heißt
nachdem die Stromproduktion unterbrochen
wurde gekühlt werden muss das weg mit
den radioaktiven Zerfallsprozessen
zusammen und dafür braucht man Strom
normalerweise bei Einzelanlagen wie sie
hier in Deutschland stehen zum Beispiel
die drei Anlagen die zurzeit in
Deutschland noch betrieben werden würde
dieser Strom wenn der Reaktor
abgeschaltet ist über das Landesnetz
bereitgestellt werden dazu hat das
Kraftwerk mehrere Verbindungsleitungen
zum Landesnetz und auch mehrere
servicestromleitungen so dass
sichergestellte dass immer Strom
bereitsteht um den Reaktor nachzukühlen
das haben wir im Normalfall hier in der
Ukraine auch es gibt vier große
hauptstromleitungen mit einer Spannung
von 750 Kilovolt die in das ukrainische
Landesnetz einspeisen und dieses
versorgen dann gibt es eine 330 Kilo
Volt Leitung die zu einem umspannpunkt
in der Nähe des Kraftwerk führte auch
ins ukrainische Landesnetz gehen eine
330 kW Leitung zu einem Wärmekraftwerk
was als
reservekraftwerk für die Versorgung des
Standortes saporicia dient und 150 Kilo
Volt 150 Kilowatt spannungsleitungen die
auch als reserverleitung geht und
normalerweise ist es so dass
mindestens eine dieser Leitungen immer
zur Verfügung stehen muss wenn alle
sechs Reaktoren abgeschaltet sind um den
Standort versorgen zu können der Vorteil
an diesen Standort ist dass ich sechs
Reaktoren habe das heißt wenn ein
Reaktor in Betrieb ist so wie wir es
jetzt haben derzeit ist der Reaktor 6 in
Betrieb dann kann der Standort sich
alleine versorgen diese Situation haben
wir jetzt
das heißt es sozusagen
trotzdem das fünf abgeschaltet sind kann
man dann überhaupt von dem Normalbetrieb
sprechen ist das so ja kann man also es
ist sicherlich ein Zustand den wir in
der Geschichte des Kraftwerkes bis dato
so nicht hatten das fünf Reaktoren
gleichzeitig abgeschaltet waren aber die
fünf Reaktoren die abgeschaltet sind
befinden sich im nachkühlbetrieb Reaktor
1 ist entladen das sind die
Brennelemente im Brennelement
Lagerbecken die Reaktoren zwei bis drei
befinden sich im ganz normalen
nachkühlbetrieb das heißt die Wärme wird
aus den Reaktoren abgeführt mittels
Pumpen und Kühlsystem und der Reaktor 6
ist in Betrieb auf einer niedrigeren
Leistung um den Standort aus eigener
Kraft versorgen zu können das heißt
zurzeit braucht man am Standort keinen
Strom von außen für den Fall der Fälle
das Reaktor 6 auch abgeschaltet würde
dann hätte man jetzt wieder zwei
Leitungen von außen die den Standort
versorgen könnten verstanden es gibt
noch den Aspekt der
Kommunikationseinrichtung in der
Notfallzentrale ein wichtiger Ort und da
ist eben auch die Sorge groß dass die
gerade nicht so richtig ja betrieben
werden können wie da der Stand und was
braucht es aus ihrer Sicht um das zu
verbessern also was wir wissen ist das
ist das was Herr gross die letzten
Donnerstag auch gesagt hat das ist keine
Zutritt zum sogenannten Krisenzentrum
gegeben hat das Krisenzentrum ist das
Hauptquartier der russischen Truppen und
auch der Mitarbeiter von Ross Atom das
ist der russische Kraftwerksbetreiber
oder die Firma in Russland die quasi
auch die Kernkraftwerke in Russland
betreibt
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es auch am
Standort noch andere
Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten und andere
Räume es gibt sogenannte notwarten in
jedem Reaktor von dem man den Reaktor
auch durchaus führen könnte das
Krisenzentrum ist ein
Kommunikationszentrum es hat für die
Sicherheit der Anlage keine ursächliche
oder direkte Bedeutung sondern das dient
quasi der Arbeit eines Krisenteams um
mit Kommunikationsmitteln die die Lage
beherrschen zu können
Sebastian stranski mit den ersten
Einschätzungen zum heute veröffentlichen
Sicherheitsbericht im Atomkraftwerk
saporischer wir sprechen gleich im
weiteren Verlauf der Sendung noch mal
weiter Herr stranski auch über den
Ausblick über mögliche Reparaturarbeiten
vielen Dank bis zu diesem Moment an Sie
und wir holen jetzt zu uns in den Stream
Katrin Eigendorf das ist unsere
Korrespondentin vor Ort in der Ukraine
die hat das immer wieder für uns im
Blick ist jetzt auch wieder auf dem Weg
nach Kiew hallo schönen guten Abend
Katrin schön dass du die Zeit für uns
gefunden hast
hallo guten Abend Katrin noch immer
reden wir über das Atomkraftwerk wir
reden noch immer über ein Atomkraftwerk
mitten im Kriegsgebiet das Russland
zuerst angeriffen und besetzt hat und
noch immer gibt es auch nach heute keine
Veränderung darüber wie blickst du auf
diese Thematik auf die Situation nach
dem heute veröffentlichten Bericht
also der heute veröffentlichte Begriff
Bericht hat ja noch mal sehr präzise
eigentlich die Bedrohungslage
zusammengefasst und ihr habt ja gerade
in dem Gespräch auch schon erörtert der
größte Faktor und die größte Gefahr
liegt natürlich in menschlichem Versagen
und man kann sich vorstellen die
Mitarbeiter die jetzt noch im Kraftwerk
tätig sind unter welchem Druck und
welcher Angst die ihren Job noch machen
und wie groß eigentlich die Gefahr dafür
Fehler ist von Anfang an hat das Thema
Besetzung von Kernkraftwerken ja in
diesem Krieg eine wesentliche Rolle
gespielt ich erinnere mich ganz zu
Anfang des Krieges war das Thema
Tschernobyl die Russen haben ja auch
Tschernobyl besetzt und wir hatten da
auch eine eine sehr sehr brisante Lage
die vielen vielen Menschen hier Sorge
gemacht hat und jetzt ist in SAP Parisi
die Lage im Prinzip noch viel viel
dramatischer wir haben das ja gerade
gehört im Beitrag und auch in dem
Gespräch was da auf dem Spiel steht dass
ein Kernkraftwerk im Mittelpunkt eines
Krieges steht unter Beschuss die
Mitarbeiter unter diesen
Stresssituationen arbeiten müssen das
ist etwas was meiner Meinung meiner
Meinung nach Teil der russischen
Kriegsstrategie ist denn wie gesagt wir
haben es nicht nur jetzt in saporisur
mit sondern eine Situation zu tun
sondern wir Russen haben das direkt zu
Anfang schon mit Tschernobyl ähnlich
praktiziert wo ein Kernkraftwerk unter
Beschuss geriet und unter Besatzung
geriet wichtig dass du das gerade
ansprichst denn es gibt so zumindest
lesen wir es auch hier und und Hörens
auch gerade so ein bisschen Verwirrung
über die aktuelle Situation es ist ein
Ping pong-spiel zwischen den Vorwürfen
zumindest liest man das so aber du
sprichst gerade den entscheidenden Punkt
an gib mir mal in die Chronologie welche
Vorwürfe sind das genau und wie war die
Chronologie
also der Vorhof ist hier ist ja ganz
klar von russischer Seite hier wieder
muss man sagen das können wir natürlich
nicht nachprüfen dass die Ukrainer
selber das Kraftwerk beschießen um
eine Situation herzustellen die ganze
Welt noch mal aufmerksam macht und dass
die Russen das Werk umstellt und
verteidigt haben aber wenn man sich das
jetzt mal überlegt was berichten
Augenzeugen die gesehen haben was vor
Ort passiert und was ist auch plausibel
ist es natürlich wieder eine denkbar
absurde Version der russischen Seite von
dem das was da wirklich vor Ort passiert
die Ukraine hat natürlich keiner
keinerlei Interesse und kann keinerlei
Interesse daran haben ja eine ihrer
hauptstromerzeuger erstens mal lahm zu
legen und hier ein nuklearen Fallout zu
provozieren
also man muss diese Lage einfach ganz
klar so sehen dass die russische Seite
hier in diesem Krieg immer wieder
Kernkraftwerke auch zum Krieg
Schauplatz macht und damit ja nicht nur
den Ukrainern Angst und Schrecken
einjagt ich bin relativ erstaunt mit ja
wie viel Gelassenheit viele Leute das
die die Lage hier noch sehen die anderen
wirklich brandgefährlich ist sondern das
ist ja auch ein Signal Richtung Europa
wo diese Situation für Angst und
Schrecken sorgt
ja absolut du hast es auch angespricht
angesprochen Angst und Schrecken wird
verbreitet und natürlich auch
Forderungen aber auch von der
ukrainischen politischen Seite wir hören
ja ganz kurz in ein Statement rein von
Präsident selenski was er zu der ganzen
Situation sagt
die letzte Hochspannungsleitung die das
AKW zum ukrainischen Stromnetz verbunden
hat wurde durch einen weiteren
provokativen russischen Beschuss
beschädigt
bereits zum zweiten Mal ist das AKW
saporicia nur knapp einer atomaren
Katastrophe entkommen
der Beschuss des Geländes zeigt das dem
Terrorstaat egal ist was die IAEA
mitteilen wird er kümmert sich nicht
darum was die internationale
Gemeinschaft beschließen wird Russland
ist nur daran interessiert die Situation
für möglichst lange Zeit brenzlig zu
halten
auch da unterstreicht er noch mal das
was er was du gerade auch gesagt hast
und er benutzt auch den Begriff der
Demilitarisierung Kathrin was
meinstelensky damit genau und warum
könnte das auch wichtig sein für den
weiteren Kriegsverlauf
also das ist ja eigentlich die
Hauptforderung der Ukraine wenn es um
die Situation in der Anlage geht dass
sie sagen ein Kernkraftwerk darf nicht
im Mittelpunkt einer Kriegssituation
stehen egal von welcher Seite und es
darf auch nicht die Situation sein dass
die Ukraine da in die Lage kommen müssen
dieses Kraftwerk auch zu verteidigen das
heißt mit dem Militarisierung meint
selensky dass er gerne das Kraftwerk am
besten um unter internationale
Beobachtungsstellen will und komplett
alles Militär dort abgezogen werden muss
das ist natürlich Wunschdenken das weiß
er auch weil bis jetzt macht die
russische Seite überhaupt gar keine
Anzeichen da dafür dass sie bereit ist
einer solchen
demilitarisierungsaktion zuzustimmen
aber das ist im Prinzip das wichtigste
Ziel weil wir haben es im Gespräch
gehört es gibt viele verschiedene
Faktoren die die Situation
brandgefährlich machen so lange dort ja
militärspräsent sind und ohne das
sicherzustellen kann das
du kannst aber kann das Kernkraftwerk
nicht mehr ja im sicheren Betrieb
geführt werden und auch nicht
ausgeschaltet werden wenn man das haben
wir auch gehört das Werk nicht einfach
jetzt nach Belieben immer wieder aus und
abgeschaltet werden kann auch das stellt
ja eine große Gefahr da ja absolut du
bist mittlerweile auch wieder für uns in
Kiew angekommen und du beobachtest die
Situation um den Krieg ganz intensiv für
uns hast immer wieder die aktuellen
Eindrücke wie ist gerade wir sprechen
gerade auch ja über einen ein
Wunschdenken oder einen eine Forderung
von selenski wie ist denn gerade der
aktuelle Stand sowohl
militärisch-strategisch als auch
generell von der Stimmung her was
erlebst du
also erstaunlicherweise erlebe ich dass
die Ukrainer trotz der vielen vielen
Opfer dieser Krieg mittlerweile ja mit
sich bringt und trotz der Tatsache dass
sie ja jetzt auch in eine Situation
kommen wo ihnen ein harter Winter
bevorsteht ja der die Situation noch mal
jetzt schlimmer macht und diesen Krieg
noch mal bitterer macht nach wie vor
entschlossen sind diesen Krieg weiter zu
führen und zurück nicht zurückzuweichen
was man sich natürlich jetzt fragen muss
wir haben hier mit zwei verschiedenen
Situationen an der Front zu tun wir
haben einmal die Südfront wo die Ukraine
vor allem rund um die Stadt und Region
dabei sind von großen besetzte Gebiete
zurück zu erobern also das große
Stichwort Rückeroberung und auf der
anderen Seite erleben wir im don-bass
also in der Ostukraine an der
ostukrainischen Front jetzt ganz ganz
harte Kämpfe wo es darum geht weiteren
Vormarsch von russischen Militärs
aufzuhalten und es stellt sich natürlich
die Frage ja wie viel
davon ist jetzt noch widerstandskrieg
und wie viel ist davon jetzt schon
rückeroberungskrieg also trotz aller
großen
Opfer ist man sich hier im Moment in der
Ukraine das höre ich zumindest von
meinen Gesprächspartnern ziemlich einig
dass das zur Strategie des Krieges nicht
nur die Verteidigung sondern jetzt auch
ganz offensiv die Rückeroberung von
besetzten Gebieten gehören muss
wir werden das weiter im Blick behalten
du wirst dass wir uns weiter vor Ort im
Blick behalten und wir werden hier
sicherlich auch weiter natürlich darüber
sprechen du wirst uns auf dem laufenden
halten vielen Dank für deine
Einschätzungen heute Abend zur Lage rund
um das AKW saporizia danke schön Katrin
Eigendorf nach Kiew
wir sprechen hier aber natürlich noch
mal weiter weil katrin hat auch gerade
noch ein ganz ganz interessanten Aspekt
bzw auch eine angstvollen Aspekt
angesprochen und das leite ich weiter an
Sebastian strandski er ist immer noch
mit uns hier im Stream dabei hallo Herr
stranski da sind sie wieder
Katrin Eickendorf hat es gerade
thematisiert die Angst in der
Bevölkerung die Angst auf ukrainischer
Seite und da kommt auch eine Frage von
uns hier im Chat per Mail und zwar von
Jan kasbrowski er fragt meine Frage ist
kann es in dem ukrainischen
Atomkraftwerk zum Supergau kommen so wie
bei Tschernobyl was würden da die
Auswirkungen sein die Angst die Katrin
Eigendorf ja auch gerade beschrieben hat
also der Begriff Super-GAU ist ja quasi
so ein volkstümlicher Begriff der einen
Kern oder den größten anzunehmenden
unfallcharakterisieren soll was ich
etwas komplex und schwierig finde ist
wenn man eine Situation wie wir sie
jetzt in saporisha haben oder auch
vielleicht in einem anderen kranker
vielleicht auch in Fukushima mit
Tschernobyl vergleichen aus meiner Sicht
ist Chernobyl eine Singularität die sich
in der Form in saporisha nicht
wiederholen könnte und das hat sowohl
technische Gründe als auch betriebliche
Gründe der Reaktortyp in Tschernobyl war
ein völlig anderer reaktor-typ als wir
ihn in saporizia haben der reaktor-typ
in Tschernobyl hatte kein Containment so
wie alle sechs Blöcke in saporicia auch
haben er hatte nicht die
Sicherheitseinrichtungen und der Unfall
in Tschernobyl kam von innen das heißt
durch ein fehlhandelndes
betriebspersonalsweisen Experiment
machen wollten ist ihnen der Reaktor
entglitten die Kontrolle in glitten und
das führte zu dieser Katastrophe wo
innerhalb kürzester Zeit der gesamte
Reaktorkern dem Himmel gegen offen war
und durch ein Graphit Feuer ein
höllenbrand entstanden ist der die
radioaktiven Stoffe hoch in die
Atmosphäre getragen hat und das hat dann
zu der Kontamination weiterteile Europas
geführt in saporisha hätten wir selbst
wenn es zu einem schweren Unfall käme
was ich immer noch für unwahrscheinlich
halte auch aufgrund der
Sicherheitseinrichtungen die die diese
reaktor-typen haben oder diese sechs
Reaktoren haben hätten wir völlig andere
Bedingungen wenn eine radioaktive Wolke
freigesetzt werden würde
es ist sicherlich eine Spekulation wie
ein solches Szenario aussehen würde wenn
es zu einem schweren Unfall käme würde
es zu einer Kontamination der Umgebung
kommen sicherlich der lokalen und
regionalen Umgebung auch wie weit diese
Kontamination dann reichen würde hängt
nicht nur von der Menge der
freigesetzten Stoffe ab und die wäre
geringer als in Tschernobyl auf jeden
Fall sondern natürlich auch von der
Windrichtung und der Wetterlage ja
wichtige Einordnung da von ihnen auch
zur Angst die im Chat auftaucht und auch
in der ukrainischen Bevölkerung Herr
stranski besprechen auch noch mal über
die generelle ja Mission der
Organisation es war eine Delegation
unterwegs zwei Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter durften länger bleiben sich
die Situation in saporicia länger
anschauen
was hat diese Mission oder was kann sie
auch im weiteren Verlauf bringen in
Sachen Öffentlichkeit in Sachen
Transparenz
sie schafft überhaupt erst einmal
Öffentlichkeit es sind derzeit zwei
Mitarbeiter vor Ort die werden auch auf
Dauer da bleiben das werden nicht immer
wieder dieselben sein die werden
sicherlich nach einer gewissen Zeit
ausgetauscht werden aber eines der Ziele
von Herrn grossy und dieser Mission war
ja eine sogenannte permanent Mission das
heißt einen eine ständige Präsenz der
IAEA vor Ort zu etablieren und das ist
gelungen dem haben also auch die Russen
zugestimmt das russische Militär so dass
zwei Mitarbeiter auch nachdem alle
anderen Mitglieder der Delegation
abgereist sind vor Ort geblieben sind
und die haben auch eine ganz konkrete
Aufgabe das kann man auch den Bericht
entnehmen der Bericht ist ein sehr
kurzgehaltener sehr kompakter Bericht
der in grundsätzlichen Aussagen und
Einschätzungen die Situation
charakterisiert gleichzeitig auch
Empfehlungen gibt wir haben über einige
dieser Empfehlung ja schon in unserem
ersten Teil im ersten Teil des
Gespräches gesprochen und basierend auf
diesen ersten Bericht sollen diese zwei
Mitarbeiter sich jetzt weiterhin gewisse
Dinge detaillierter angucken sollen auch
weiterhin das Betriebsgeschehen und auch
das militärische Geschehen am Standort
beobachten um dann natürlich direkt und
sehr sehr schnell auch Informationen an
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
und damit auch an die Weltöffentlichkeit
geben zu können das ist ein vollkommen
neuer Zustand verglichen mit dem was wir
bis zum Donnerstag letzter Woche hatten
da waren wir darauf angewiesen dass die
Mitarbeiter des Kraftwerks die
ukrainischen Beschäftigten per
Telefonleitung oder über die sozialen
Medien entweder der Aufsichtsbehörde
snru in Kiew oder dem Betreiber in Nago
Atom die Dinge vor Ort berichten konnten
oder wir waren natürlich darauf
angewiesen was das russische Militär was
das Gelände besetzt hält berichtet hat
und jetzt haben wir zum ersten Mal und
das ist aus meiner Sicht der wirklich
große Vorteil und der große nutzen
zwei Leute vor Ort die unabhängig gucken
können und die auch dass Mandat haben
unabhängig zu sprechen und die
Informationen weiterzugeben also ich
fass zusammen aus ihrer Sicht ein
wichtiger Schritt für Transparenz rund
um die Situation auch ein weiterer
vermeintlich wichtiger Schritt oder
vielleicht wichtiger Schritt es wird in
dem Bericht auch immer wieder davon
gesprochen dass es schon
Reparaturarbeiten gegeben hat oder dass
die zumindest gerade starten sollen was
wird da gemacht und wie wichtig ist auch
das in der Kürze in der nächsten Zeit
die Schäden die bisher entstanden durch
Beschuss sind alles Schäden an der
Infrastruktur das heißt zum Glück sind
sicherheitstechnisch wichtige
Einrichtungen nicht beschädigt worden
oder in ihrer Funktion beeinträchtigt
worden das ist ein Glück ob das in der
Zukunft so gilt muss man gucken ich
hoffe dass es so gilt die Schäden sind
Straßenschäden Gebäudeschäden die werden
natürlich jetzt repariert das gibt der
Bericht auch
kund- und zu wissen da steht da so drin
und das ist denke ich ganz normale
Reparaturarbeiten die den
Kraftwerksbetrieb ob jetzt die
nachkühlung der Reaktoren oder auch den
Leistungsbetrieb eines Reaktors nicht
beeinträchtigen
eine User Frage ich weiß nicht ob sie
die konkret beantworten können ich leite
sie trotzdem mal weiter auf Youtube
kommt sie von Caterpillar NATO-Truppen
sollten das AKW sichern ist sozusagen
die Forderung und auch die Einschränkung
das ist wahrscheinlich aber genauso
problematisch wie den Luftraum zu
schützen haben sie dann eine
Einschätzung zu
ich halte das für nicht machbar was
vielerlei Gründen das würde ein direktes
Eingreifen der NATO in den Krieg
bedeuten und ich denke das ist nicht
darstellbar und eine Anschlussfrage die
auch noch zu dem Aspekt gerade noch
reingekommen ist den wir thematisiert
hatten rund um Worst Case Szenarien just
a player auf Youtube fragt dann noch mal
ganz konkret sie haben gerade von falls
es weitere Schäden gibt von lokalen
Ausbrüchen gesprochen aber was wäre denn
das Schlimmste was passieren könnte
vielleicht können wir das noch mal klar
ziehen das ist sehr schwierig und
deswegen will ich das ungerne jetzt hier
wirklich so apodiktisch sagen weil ein
möglicher Unfall oder ein Störfall auch
mit Freisetzung von radioaktiven Stoffen
ist ein Szenario was sehr sehr komplex
ist man kann nicht sein das und das muss
passieren damit das und das Ergebnis
rauskommt sondern das ist wäre ein
Prozess der damit beginnt dass man die
Sicherheitseinrichtungen verliert dass
die Sicherheitsfunktion die
barrierenfunktion des Kraftwerks
verloren gegangen werden und dann hängt
es von weiteren anderen Faktoren ab
insofern jetzt zu sagen das sind das
wäre der anzunehmende Unfall das ist
etwas was man seriös so nicht
formulieren kann ja was wir vielleicht
aber seriös formulieren können ist was
in diesem Prozess den sie beschreiben
jetzt aus ihrer Sicht die nächsten
wichtigen Schritte neben der Transparenz
neben den zwei Mitarbeitern vor Ort und
neben der Reparaturarbeit ist was
braucht es dann noch
ich sag mal so das was wir Eingang schon
gesagt haben die drucken müssen abziehen
und es muss und das finde ich und würde
ich vielleicht so gerne als Quintessenz
auch unseres Gespräches
herausgearbeitet haben das Wichtigste
und es steht das ja auch hier quasi
schon am ersten Punkt des Berichtes drin
bei den erstreckhommendation das
Kraftwerk muss raus aus einem
militärisch besetzten Gebiet wo
Kampfhandlungen stattfinden und es muss
in eine sichere Zone überführt werden
Herr stanski dann lasse ich das genauso
an der Stelle stehen vielen Dank für
ihre Einschätzungen für dieses Fazit
hier heute Abend bei ZDF heute live sehr
gerne
ich bedanke mich auch bei euch natürlich
fürs zuschauen wir hoffen dass wir eure
Fragen beantworten konnten wir hoffen
dass Sie einen Überblick über die
aktuelle Situation bekommen habt und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr beim
nächsten Mal auch wieder mit bei uns am
Start seid bis dahin macht's gut tschüss